millions of plastic bottles are thrown
away every single day used just once
these are mostly made from brand-new
plastic now coca-cola is promising to
increase the amount of recycled plastic
it uses in its bottles from just 25
percent to 50 percent by 2020 I want all
of our packet plastic packaging back
because I don't want to see it lying at
the side of the road or in the peaches
Beach any more than anybody else we're
already doing more than anybody else in
our industry to use recycled plastic but
we're going to double down on that but
is this just a drop in the ocean each
day 16 million plastic bottles are
thrown away in the UK the world's five
biggest soft drinks companies produce
over two million tons of plastic bottles
a year 12 million tonnes of plastic ends
up in the sea each year equivalent to a
dumper truck of plastic every minute
deposit returns schemes in other
countries including Norway have boosted
recycling rates up to 95 percent with
consumers paying a small deposit that's
refunded when they return the bottle but
despite pressure from campaign groups
Coca Cola's latest announcement stops
short of backing such a scheme in the UK
despite indicating support earlier this
year Coca Cola's involved in 38 deposit
return systems around the world they run
them they help design them so they know
full well that people respond well to a
finite to a financial incentive recent
figures suggest just over half around 57
percent of plastic bottles are currently
recycled in the UK which begs the
question why more of that plastic isn't
already being used to make new bottles
consumers we spoke to at this recycling
centre believe companies could and
should do more you always used to be
able to take sell bottles and stuff back
and get a deposit back on them get your
money back on them if it would help why
not do it it's hypocritical if they're
getting you to do things and
be aware but they're not doing it
themselves they make a lot of profit so
they should get back to the environment
they're contributing to the pollution so
they shouldn't do something about it but
some argue the only way to significantly
reduce the amount of plastic ending up
in our oceans is to use fewer bottles in
the first place Becky Johnson Sky News